wir bewerben uns auf verdächtige
Stellenangebote
gesucht
Ukrainerinnen ab 17 Jahren
der Anbieter fühlt sich offenbar sicher
im Chat erklärt er worum es geht Sex vor
der Webcam
drei bis fünf Minuten videotelefonieren
in Unterwäsche
in Wien kämpfen die Experten der OSZE
gegen Menschenhandel sie beobachten
solche Anzeigen mit Sorge
wir wissen das Google suchen nach
sexdiensten ukrainischer Frauen und
Mädchen in die Höhe geschossen sind
diese Daten zeigen uns dass es für
Menschenhändler einen Anreiz gibt Frauen
und Mädchen in großem Umfang anzuwerben
weil sich damit Geld verdienen lässt
sie sammeln Verdächtige Stellenangebote
und geben sie an die nationalen
Polizeibehörden weiter
uns weisen sie auf weitere
ausbeuterische Angebote hin wohnen im
Tausch gegen Sex
wir schalten an der Cover ein
Wohnungssuche in Berlin wir bekommen
fast 30 Angebote
20 klingen verdächtig ein Beispiel
du würde sagen warum möchtest du mir
helfen
ich suche eine Freundin die mit mir
wohnt in seiner eigenen Wohnung wenn ich
mit dir zusammen lebe bin ich doch nicht
gezwungen irgendwas zu machen oder
da hat er andere Vorstellungen
ein bisschen Sex
der nächste bietet für 600 Euro ein
Zimmer an aber am Preis könne man was
machen sagt er
wenn du meine Freundin bist dann jeden
Monat 400 wir haben uns auf vier
Anzeigen gemeldet bei dreien geht es am
Ende um Sex
auch wenn offizielle Zahlen fehlen unser
Eindruck es sind nicht nur Einzelfälle
das berichtet auch Natalia oliferovic
Kunststudentin aus Kiew jetzt in Leipzig
die ebenfalls für Ihre Wohnung mit Sex
bezahlen sollte
[Musik]
im Moment bitte ich Frauen dass sie
anonym ihre Erlebnisse schildern
als Reaktion hat sie eine Website
gegründet für Ukrainerinnen die anonym
ihre Missbrauchs Erfahrungen
veröffentlichen in der ersten Woche
waren es gleich 20
als sich das alles gelesen habe dachte
ich was bitte ist hier los Deutschland
müsste sich einer unbequem Realität
stellen
wenn wir nur über Zahlen reden hat
Deutschland gute Arbeit geleistet mit
Geld und Förderung
aber diese Berichte zeigen eine andere
Realität ich glaube sie könnten den
deutschen zeigen dass diese Probleme
existieren
die Schilderungen auf der Website sind
detailliert und erscheinen uns plausibel
eine Betroffene berichtet anonym ein
Mann in Berlin habe ihr eine Wohnung
versprochen und sie dann in einem Park
bedrängt später muss sie ins Krankenhaus
sie hat Verletzungen an den
Oberschenkeln den Armen und im
Genitalbereich
[Musik]
dennoch geht sie zunächst nicht zur
Polizei der Grund sie sei mit der
Situation überfordert gewesen
stell dir vor dein Mann kämpft gerade in
der Ukraine und du erlebst sowas du
willst nicht schon wieder das Opfer sein
du kennst die Sprache nicht und bist
schon als Opfer hierher gekommen und
dann wirst du noch sexuell belästigt
geflüchtete Ukrainerinnen in Deutschland
einige von ihnen geraten auf einen
anderen Weg den Weg in die bezahlte
Sexarbeit
Gerhard Schönborn von der
Hilfsorganisation Neustart betreut
Prostituierte in Berlin
wir machen aufsuchende Arbeit in
Bordellen und was wir dann da drin waren
waren wir erstaunt dass alles
ausschließlich Frauen aus der Ukraine
drin waren alle geflüchtet in der
geflüchteten Unterkunft teils mit
Kindern
der Mann im Krieg also
zumindestens für Berlin kann man sehen
dass das im Bereich der Produktion als
eine sehr große Zunahme gab an Frauen
aus der Ukraine
merkwürdig ist nur laut den Behörden hat
die Zahl der ukrainischen Frauen in der
Prostitution gar nicht zugenommen was
stimmt
wir recherchieren vor Ort und besuchen
an der Cover Sex und erotikbetriebe
gleich im ersten sitzen nach ein paar
Minuten zwei Frauen neben uns
Ukrainerinnen
10% der Frauen seien jetzt von dort
berichten Sie
diese Frau wurde gerade für ein Separé
gebucht sie ist erst vor zwei Monaten
von der Front statt Person nach
Deutschland geflohen
diese 35-Jährige berichtet uns dass sie
ihren ausgebomben Eltern eine Wohnung in
Kiel finanzieren muss
[Musik]
und diese Frau erzählt sie sei in der
Bürokratie des Jobcenters gescheitert
und brauche dringend Geld
in sieben von zehn Betrieben treffen wir
auf Ukrainerinnen wir treffen auf Frauen
in Ausnahmesituationen unter
finanziellem Druck ohne
Deutschkenntnisse
was sagt die Polizei dazu
das betrifft Frauen aus allen Ländern
und
nicht nur nicht nur ukrainische
geflüchtete dass die in Deutschland
diese Entscheidung treffen können das
ist bei uns das Gesetz
ja und solange wir keine Hinweise auf
eine Straftat haben die damit verknüpft
ist haben wir auch keinen Anlass da
etwas zu tun keine Hinweise auf
Straftaten kein Grund zum Handeln das
hat Folgen im Kampf gegen den
Menschenhandel und Ausbeutung
[Musik]
das erleben wir hier an der
EU-Außengrenze in den Hügeln der
Karpaten zwischen Rumänien und der
Ukraine
hier waren zu Kriegsbeginn tausende
Ukrainerinnen viele mit dem Ziel
Deutschland und hunderte Helfer die
Helfer sind jetzt weg
die Flüchtlinge kommen weiter je nachdem
wie stark die Kämpfe auf der anderen
Seite der Grenze sind in der Woche in
der wir vor Ort sind kommen an diesem
Grenzübergang 500 Menschen
[Musik]
und er will sie vom Menschenhändlern
schützen die sie mit dem Versprechen von
schnellem Geld locken rasan Fabian und
sein Team haben mindestens 12
geflüchtete vor diesem Schicksal bewahrt
jetzt werden ihm internationale
Hilfsgelder gekürzt
[Musik]
wenn die Finanzierung gestrichen ist
geht es meines Erachtens erst richtig
los denn die Menschenhändler wollen das
sie wollen dass die Flüchtlinge in
Schwierigkeiten geraten wenn ich auch
noch weg bin wird es für sie
wahrscheinlich einfacher
[Musik]
vor kurzem hatte er noch neuen
Mitarbeiter bald muss er ganz aufhören
finanzielle Kürzungen verantworten auch
nationale Behörden wie die deutsche
Polizei wenn sie Entwarnung geben
dabei wäre Prävention gerade jetzt
wichtig
jetzt ist es gefährlich 8 Millionen
ukrainische Flüchtlinge die irgendwie
einen Weg finden müssen um zu überleben
und das angesichts steigen der Preise
und Schrumpfen der Volkswirtschaften all
das zusammen ist ein Cocktail der
Menschenhandel in einem nie bekannten
Ausmaß begünstigt
die OSZE hat Daten ausgewertet mit jedem
Anstieg der Asylanträge steigt auch
wenig später die Zahl der ermittelten
Opfer von Menschenhandel
wir können uns nicht erlauben zu denken
in den ersten zwölf Monaten haben wir
keinen einzigen Fall gefunden gute
Arbeit Problem gelöst nein jetzt ist der
Moment gekommen sie zu unterstützen und
dafür zu sorgen dass sie nicht in die
Hände von Menschenhändlern fallen denn
jetzt sind sie gefährdeter als jemals
zuvor